what about the little criticism I saw of
do you
uh by way of question do you consider
the different probabilities of each
reaction in the chain so like that there
could be
different when you look at a chain of
events that led up to the creation of an
object doesn't it matter that some parts
in the chain are less likely than others
no it doesn't matter no no well let's
back so no not less lightly but react so
so so no so let's go back to what we're
talk looking at so the assembly index is
the minimal path that could have created
that object probabilistically so imagine
you have all your atoms in a plasma you
got enough energy you got enough um
there's collisions what is the quickest
way you could zip out that molecule with
no reaction constraints how do you
define quickest there then it's just
basically walk on a random graph so you
so we make an assumption that basically
the time scale for forming the bonds so
no I don't want to say that because it's
going to have people getting obsessing
about this point and your criticism is a
really good one what we're trying to say
is like this is this puts a lower bound
on something of course um some reactions
are less possible than others but
actually I don't think chemical
reactions exist oh boy what does that
mean why don't chemical reactions exist
I'm writing a paper right now that that
um I keep being told I have to finish
and it's called the origin of chemical
reactions and it merely says that
reactivity exists as controlled by the
laws of quantum mechanics and reactions
we put names chemist put names on
reactions like so you could have like I
don't know the vitic reaction which is
by you know vitic um you could have the
Suzuki reaction which is by Suzuki now
what are these reactions so these
reactions are constrained by the
following they're constrained by the
fact they're on planet Earth 1G MH 298
Kelvin one bar
so these are constraints mhm um they're
also constrained by the chemical
composition of Earth oxygen availability
all this stuff and that then allows us
to focus in our chemistry so when a
chemist does a reaction that's a really
nice compressed short hand for
constraint application glass flask pure
reagent temperature pressure bom bom bom
bom bom control control control control
control so of course we have Bond
energies yes this so the bond energy is
kind of intrinsic in a vacuum if you say
so the bond energy you have to have a
bond and so for assembly Theory to work
you have to have a bond which means that
bond has to give the molecule certain a
half life so you'll probably going to
find later on that some bonds are weaker
and that you are going to miss in Mass
Spectra when you count look at the
Assembly of some molecules you're going
to miscount the assembly of the molecule
because it falls apart too quickly
because the bonds just form but you can
solve that with looking infared so so
when people think about the probability
they're kind of
misunderstanding asembly Theory says
nothing about the chemistry because
chemistry is chemistry and the
constraints are put in by biology there
was no chemist on the origin of Life B
unless you believe in the chemist in the
sky and they were you know it's like
Santa Claus they had a lot of work to do
but but chemical reactions do not exist
in the constraints that allow chemical
transformations to occur do exist okay
okay so it's constraint applic so it's
there's no chemical reactions it's all
constraint application Y which enables
the
emergence of
Rea of what's a different word for
chemical reaction uh transformation
transformation yeah like a function it's
a function but no but I love chemical
reactions the shorthand and and and so
the chemists don't all go mad I mean of
course chemical reactions exist on Earth
short hand it's a short hand for these
constraints for for right so assuming
all these constraints that we've been
using for so long we just assume that
that's always the case yeah in natural
language conversation exactly the
grammar of chemistry of course emerges
in reactions and we can use them
reliably but I do not think the vitic
reaction is accessible on Venus right
and this is useful to remember you know
to to to frame it as constraint
application is useful for when you zoom
out to the bigger picture of the
universe and looking at the chemistry of
the universe and then starting to apply
assembly Theory that's interesting
that's really
interesting